another reason why the kaepernick angle
is prevalent over the weekend joe
lockhart who was the nfl's chief
spokesman during the anthem controversy
a former white house press secretary
wrote a column at cnn.com
acknowledging that
he believes that in hindsight the league
should have found a way to get colin
kaepernick employed in the aftermath of
that anthem controversy with
the
the
rancor that emerged between the
president and the owners and the players
in 2017
and one of the things lockhart writes is
that there was one owner
who said to lockhart that that owner's
team projected losing 20 percent of
their season ticket holders if they
signed colin kaepernick so
you know it's
it's one thing to say
that
the nfl supports these causes but
if supporting them means you're going to
lose money that it's going to be bad for
business then that's where the support
ends and
lockhart tried i think to exonerate the
league by saying the league office did
all it could to get colin kaepernick on
a team it's the teams that were at fault
for not signing him
but they all rallied around this idea
that it's going to be bad for business
to do it it's too controversial of
course we heard all of the the arguments
that were made at the time that were
supposedly football related but they
were primarily aimed at justifying this
business decision
but that's ultimately
what happened a business decision was
made
to
pay more attention
to those who
were mad about what kaepernick was doing
than to pay attention to those who
supported what he was doing
and i i think that the people who were
mad about it and the people who
supported it
is a fairly equal number
but the people who were mad about it
were being really really loud about it
and yeah i think it shouted down the
owners and it and it scared them into
not doing this and lockhart's point is
that the nfl should should sign
kaepernick now and he mentions the
vikings because minneapolis is the
epicenter of this look i think at this
point and chris given everything that's
happened between the two sides there's
been a lawsuit essentially it's a formal
arbitration proceeding under the cba but
it's still basically a lawsuit a
settlement seven-figure settlement of
that lawsuit the workout that was set up
by the league last year kind of out of
the blue the mistrust between the two
sides that resulted in the
disintegration of the workout
poison
so much poison between the league its
teams in kaepernick at this point i i
think that that you know la i don't know
if lockhart is just trying to gain
absolution for his role in this but it's
not practical at this point to expect
that kaepernick and any team are going
to find the middle ground necessary no
to get a deal done the one team the one
the one guy that he would not be leery
of right now is mark davis mark davis
doesn't need him he's got derek carr and
marcus mariota but if i'm kaepernick i'm
going to be leery
especially now oh you're calling me now
i know why you're calling me now what
what you know i'm not going to be your
pr tool here you had four years to sign
me i mean i could see him have that
reaction so there's a lot of vitriol on
both sides there's a lot of of dislike
and animosity on both sides and just
because joe lockhart wrote a column
saying someone should do it i don't
think anybody's going to do it and in
part because i'm not sure kaepernick is
going to want to do it under these
circumstances and under these terms
right i don't think kaepernick wants to
be used i mean for one you know it's two
mike i mean the point you talked about
you know one owner saying they'd lose 20
percent of their revenue or whatever it
may be you know i don't know how much it
is but still that threat's real to where
teams are still going to be worried
about that even in times like this
and you know even more than that too
what we talked about with this issue hey
with coaches you know especially
especially a football team and
everything like that hey i think there's
a lot of head coaches in football that
you know want colin kaepernick the
player on their football team it's just
like we talked about at the time mike
you know it's the it's the distraction
of what it could do to your football
team as well i think that scares a lot
of coaches off right or wrong i'm just
telling you i think that's what the fact
of the matter is so yes unfortunately
colin kaepernick you know is is a a
martyr for for something that you know
he's he stood for and of course yeah he
got screwed over there's no other way to
put it he deserved to be in the nfl but
that time has come and gone now it's
four years it's too tough to come back
and play quarterback after not playing
for four years uh he's certainly yes
we'll go away distraction look that that
distraction angle just makes my blood
boiled up but you're right it's real
because and here's here's what it is if
you're good enough they'll welcome the
distraction kaepernick wasn't so
obviously
great that you just said oh hey it
doesn't matter we're trying to win
football games i'm trying to get a new
contract i'm trying to keep my job i'm
trying to build a legacy here this guy's
great if it was patrick mahomes for
example you'd welcome the distraction
um distraction is just a way to and and
it gets applied to all sorts of
different things it's basically a coach
saying i got enough to worry about i
don't need to have this thrown on top of
my day-to-day existence as i try to run
my team it's unfortunate that that's the
way it is but it is the way it is and uh
look i'll just say this as we take a
break uh because then i want to talk
about the quarterbacks who have
decided to come out and issue statements
chris and you'll have some perspective
on that since you were a quarterback in
the nfl
but if the league really wanted back in
2017 for colin kaepernick to be on a
team
if the league really wanted it to happen
as joe lockhart seems to suggest now if
the league really wanted it to occur it
would have happened it would there are
ways to get these things agreed there
are back room deals that happen all the
time hey you want a super bowl you know
how you enhance your super bowl bid you
sign colin kaepernick hey you want a
draft you know how you enhance your
draft bid you sign colin kaepernick or
just other stuff there's all sorts of
stuff that at any given time chris a
team wants they're lobbying the league
all the time deals get done all the time
if they really wanted
i'm gonna leave it at that if they
really wanted to get kaepernick in the
league in 2017
they they could have made it happen
if they really wanted
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports